[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance the well-dressed man in the
neatly trimmed beard was one of the last
of the 558 people to testify to the
Commission he had been chosen by his
colleagues to represent them all and
none of them publicly disavowed what he
said nor ever would his colleagues have
been willing to paralyze the nation to
affect not just at least 10% of the
economy but to at best inconvenience and
to at worst literally threaten the lives
of virtually all of its citizens no
matter what entreaties have been made to
them no matter what evidence of
inhumanity had been presented no matter
the pleas and protestations no matter
the moving spectacle of Horrors as one
of their opponents termed it they would
not listen they had a mandate to protect
what their side believed and their side
had all the money and then the
well-dressed man and the neatly trimmed
beard said something that you can still
find in the history books today of the
victims of the inhumanity he and his
moneyed colleagues were inflicting he
testified quote these men don't suffer
why he'll half of them don't even speak
English the man was named George F Baer
and he was the president of the
Philadelphia and Reading Railroad on his
testimony was to the first real public
hearing about the hellish murderous
virtual slavery facing the coal miners
of this nation the Commission was called
the anthracite coal Commission this was
in the year 1903 in Pennsylvania the
miners often worked ten hours a day six
days a week for which they would be paid
as little as two dollars and 75 cents an
hour the boys who worked in the mines
made as little as 13 cents per hour and
George F Baer was as were all the
moneyed men of the coal and railroad
industries defending this who bear had
become their spokesman because a letter
he had written had leaked and been
published the rights and interests of
the laboring man will be protected and
cared for not by the labor agitators but
by the Christian men of property to whom
God has given control of the property
rights of this country that made him a
hero he would defend the millionaires
who
boys of twelve and eleven and ten and
nine and eight years old to straddle a
conveyor on which travelled the shale
their fathers were sending up from the
pits half a mile below the surface they
literally broke up the oversized pieces
or if they did it wrong the oversized
pieces would break them up and as the
Commission heard could easily take off a
boy's hand or his arm or his leg for
thirteen cents an hour these men don't
suffer why hell half of them don't even
speak English I've been thinking a lot
lately of George F Bear and the other
demons of the 1902 oh three coal strike
I hope there is a hell solely for people
like them they exist in all generations
therefore you have man's duty to other
men twisted and perverted and
unimaginable by nearly all the rest of
us and roundly cheered by the sadistic
and the money obsessed and the
comfortable they exist today they are
the people like Donald Trump and Paul
Ryan and the others involved in the
repeal of the often ineffective long
from finished first step towards
establishing the absolute and the
inalienable right of every man and woman
and child in this country to have their
health
minimally protected through the
intervention of the government that
first step they have derisive Lee called
Obamacare Trump and his ilk look at the
transplant recipients who gained new
life under Obamacare and will now have
no means of paying for the drugs to keep
themselves alive and they shrug and
congratulate themselves on tax cuts for
themselves Trump and his ilk look at the
special-needs kids who will have no
insurance and see only quote liberal
tears Trump and his ilk will look at the
as yet uncountable number of poor people
who will die because of the greed of the
rich and they will celebrate what they
actually believe is a victory these men
don't suffer why hell half of them don't
even vote Republican George F Bear died
103 years and one month ago and I hope
he is still suffering somewhere all that
he knew the railroad industry and the
coal industry that used to dominate this
nation it's all gone
without the government there would be no
train service at all in this country and
coal mining is an actor thought no
matter Trump's false promises and child
labor is in retrospect impossible to
believe but man's inhumanity to man
lives on in Donald Trump and Paul Ryan
and in every other so-called human being
who fought to repeal the Affordable
Health Care Act be heartbroken be
terrified be angry but mostly become ly
vengeful quietly persistently
permanently vengeful to Trump and Ryan
and every so-called man and woman who
voted for this medieval act this
barbarism we know your names we will
destroy your careers we will make you
suffer and like George F Baer and the
mine owners if any of the religions of
the world are correct future generations
will comfort themselves and move forward
into the light driven in part by the
comfort of knowing that you Paul Ryan
and you Donald Trump are burning in hell
resist peace